yeah what's doing I think I want to try
to do a podcast Oh what what's that well
I talk about what I do during the day
and maybe conversations because I never
heard that term so what is it you of
what you do during the day and maybe
joel wants to be on it he thinks he'd be
a good critic a TV critic that he'd be
the best they're waiting for him to be a
film critic you know what I mean well
maybe he could call it yeah calling in
is different so what do you put it on
the Internet yeah yeah so bad I don't
have it I never heard that term before
what is the name again the podcast pot
k.s.p OT p.o.d CA esti all right I never
heard that term ok i'm fred stoller
that's my mother who doesn't know what a
podcast is and let's hope I know what
one is because i'm going to try to do
one and this is i think my first
official one i did a trial last week and
we it's taken a while i have a title the
mild what is that clicking in the ear is
something bad are we okay okay here's
the title them give me a chance to think
of what it was the mild Adventures of
fred stoller and maybe there'll be a
theme with music and and because what do
i do tur with ulcers yeah people my
mother always says what do you do during
the day and it seems like i don't do
anything but I walk around I try to
decide what to eat people annoy me or
all right sometimes have a good
conversation I i'm going to introduce
these two really great people but i want
to do a first just an example of what
happened today an adventure i i i i i
could I always want to say
I wrote the book on the guest our life I
literally did maybe we'll have you back
I'm a guest our guy another than a
regular so my landlord looked me up on
the Internet got savvy cuz you've been
on a lot of shows i didn't know you're
rich i go i'm not and he sees all these
credits my friend's son said dad fred
has more credits than a famous person
see if I just was on Becker for four
years just said that one credit I don't
a house but it looks like I'm rich so he
goes you know you're taking advantage
this is a great area you should move out
and buy a house because I could raise
the rent so so I'm freaked out he's
trying to think of a way to get rid of
me so I this is how sick I am I go to
the farmers market I hope to bump into
other character actors because i
commiserate ii and i want to do like a
cribs for like character act as I asked
this guy could I film your house to show
my landlord that just because you have a
lot of credit to you don't live in a big
house so so I I have that book i
mentioned and i did these events fred
stoller and the guest stars a comedy try
to promote it so we had larry Hanken and
he told such great stories and so I
guess this is the introduction now um so
many things and I were he's one of these
guys everything you should write a book
has you been oh wait a minute that's
been done now maybe you could do he was
just to name a few he played Kramer on
Seinfeld the show within the show the
pilot mr. heckles on friends the
junkyard guy on Breaking Bad I I got
questions I have to ask him about WKRP
in Cincinnati escape from alcatraz
Laverne and Shirley I'm not even reading
this off a thing now I became aware of
you I always knew you at home alone will
get into stories and amber tourism is
sitting at how it ties right so i won't
get the she said if she feels sorry for
someone she makes out with them so I
blew my my I used are used to okay well
now I don't even get any anything
because i missed the name up but I
bumped into her far
market this morning walking around they
hope to have interactions and
commiserate and so I said what we've
been talking about yes she's gonna come
here hey she's really big on Twitter
she's written on lots of shows she's got
things going on and she's got a very
smart five now Larry one of my first
Jobs was my worst one because they were
trying to fire me singer in sons and you
were on that and that's where we became
sort of friendly yeah and you played
Speier did it do you always put do you
always play the same kind of like you
know homeless kind of yeah you know
kinda got that was a choice I met I made
that choice that I cuz I didn't want to
put on costumes and I don't want to get
dress tonight oh yeah i do want to shave
so I said let me just play all these
homeless guys and then I've developed it
into a feature movie now I think yeah
yeah we'll talk about if anyone's
listening things to promote he's lying
you know to you don't look I don't want
to get cocky go here you could promote
things I've been on so many podcast
where it's someone doing skype in
Minneapolis was not always Minneapolis
some guy in their apartment they go hey
what would you like to plug Fred like no
one's listening yes so I don't want to
be delusional hey you could promote your
thing you never know but I'm hoping to
do something where if this fans and and
just do it every week and and talk and
and hope that I'm on a less therapy yeah
yeah and now look I want it we did an
event at flappers and you kind of got
mad at me because I was trying to
compliment you I I introduced you and it
came out the wrong way I said you're
under rated meaning people do this to me
either they think I'm the biggest
celebrity oh do you need a writer's
assistant and they don't know I'm just
some guy like napping all day or they go
how come you never made it no I didn't
say that they go how come you haven't
made it cuz Larry's similar in that he's
done a million things but never hit the
big home run and stuff so I said under
it so he played when you were a Kramer
you were so good yes
so funny I didn't you know I said but
you said it's your choice you could have
been cream Michael Richards is a genius
yeah but you could have just as easily
been on Seinfeld for nine years and you
would at crane would have been different
we've been angry and edgy or a darkness
but I'm just saying you're I know it
sounds wrong he's as genius a character
actor is Jim Carrey so much but again
i'm well how could you [ __ ] i learn
yeah well cuz let's make this I've this
just come up a lot so I think I've right
kind of figured it out no I uh first of
all I don't like I have a learning
disability ADHD but it's pretty serious
and so I ate before it was everyone had
it yeah yeah but I've had it since
housing a kid and never knew it why it's
different if you know it but if you
don't know it man it it becomes a
mystery as to why you're misinterpreting
information is I thought that was right
but it's wrong so I one of the things as
you you it's hard for me to memorize
lines so I would avoid any thing that
was too many lines and the more pay you
get the more lines you get and so I back
I have that too in a way but I don't
know if I've ADHD i just like i like
being comfortable you know that you had
it did you know about actually it it
surfaced about 10 years ago so i went
through my major creative life not
knowing I had ADHD and avoiding parts
where i had like you know a lot of lines
hope easily having an earthquake or I
thought I felt so okay um so so um so
it's my doing another in other words
what I'm saying is it's not that I am
unrecognized it's I don't know what a
beaut I didn't want to be recognized I I
said know if I'm going to memorize my a
lot of lines then I will
uh write my own stuff and memorize my
own lines and so that's that's what I
was doing okay see um we have which
developed into me now out of show
business now in turn Adam show business
and into making my own movies yeah yeah
yeah actually one of the questions we
got is you and Larry should do a podcast
ipod kasbah a web series I always liked
the chemistry with this guy like he's
the aggressive so we will try to think
of something if ya if I want a favor I
know you film so much yeah but now it's
it's it's kind of plugged in already
recently all right i'm on amana I mean
no we can still do it but in other words
i finally found people who want to do
what i want to do not what they want me
to do oh so what you're saying that you
that you've stopped trying to fit in too
yeah the hollywood and work on right i
gave up my HS they gave my baby yeah i
just said ok I'm just stepping off the
edge and it's great yeah it's good and
you're making movies I'm making my own
I'm just doing my own words and that's
it oh I what do you Alan you know I mean
Oh an elder well you know I have
something similar and I where I grew up
maybe cuz I had no confidence and I
grabbed it I was never funny it was
depressed and pathologically shy but
when I see character actors like guys
you may not know her battle man or Ron
leben or weird guys were three lines in
a movie I go I could be that I never
thought I could be Clint Eastwood
obviously or even Elliott Gould so I
remember I was seeing a shrink e because
I go I fantasize being the guy and dog
day afternoon Oh chickens out or the guy
with three lines who's that because you
should have bigger dreams than that so I
don't know if it was ADHD I just thought
that's possible like I always have
crushes on people i think may actually
look at me you know they mean so it's in
the realm of possibility so I didn't
ever think I want to be a star but then
when I got into it I thought yeah I'm
always like at the the craft service
table hearing the guy somewhere
even talk about what they can wear the
Emmys a new houses so then I go yeah I'd
like to be a regular and do more I'm not
complaining but when you say ADHD with
me but maybe I have it too because I
like yeah not the pressure and sorry for
going all this place but you have a
great story about breaking bad you're so
many great stories now you said with the
learning disability of getting lots of
material I'm you said when you had to
memorize a lot of stuff it would take me
a long time in other words one of the
things before I just tossed it all in
four years what i would do is if I would
get apart I would tell my agent to tell
them to get me the script as soon as
possible so that i would have a long
lead time to memorize is it is it what's
it called not to read some thing I have
tourettes all oh yeah what's the other
game dyslexia is it yeah okay right so
how would you memorize did you it just
takes me hours and I you know you just
repeat it over and over again but since
i didn't know i had ADHD I was forcing
it yeah finally you know I've always
showed up and memorized thought I'd you
know never blew the lines not much just
like any other acrobat so I always work
but when I found out that I had a th day
and that's why it was such a relief that
I didn't need as much time my mind
started to relax its my way you start to
now you had a label yeah yeah I love
least wish i was telling amber this
morning but by then I wanted out so it
didn't matter what I can do it a little
better but it was a relief to know that
that you're diagnosed with something I
understand touch me I yeah you know you
probably went for you smarter yeah
you're like a holy cow you know I always
wished that like I was telling amber I
wish I was an alcoholic because then I
could go I surrender I quit and my life
blossomed and my mother I always envied
people whose
mother's really hit them and threw them
down the steps because oh you have a
label my mixed messages screw up a kid
more and I once brought it to my shrink
the next session he goes I think she's
schizophrenic and even though he's on
worse shrank she's not schizophrenic but
I'm so excited yeah I got a label I
always take phone calls with my mother I
want evidence that she's messed me up I
I always say it's like the show mr. red
howdy he'd only talked for Wilbur and it
looked like it was crazy so I always
want to be validated so I know what you
mean the relief of a label and i wish i
had like something so and i had the same
thing where well i left we had the same
age and I left him after 10 years I I
didn't want to leave him because I'd
always bump into met Fred Willard
spartys and and hate confrontation and I
and I and I finally did and but tell
tell him about the breaking bad how you
overwhelmed you had so many lines you
had to do well yeah just a mic ok yeah I
was it was on the the second one the
first one I I aced because they they
invited me back so I guess I did well
but you said that's the thing I had you
not a second line at the second time I
went up on a couple of lines but I mean
all actors at some beer up on a line but
since I had that thing in the back of my
memory you know it's very hard for me
I'm very sensitive about going up on
lines were other actors just go up
online yeah do it again well to me it
was so anyway I was doing a scene with
Bryan Cranston and I went up on my lines
you know ok now that went up on my line
again you know and and this time he was
like being the guy not Brian he was
Walter White that's imitating you want
to mess up and ones of white looks at
you I didn't know whether he was being
Walter or Brian and I was screwing up or
he's just screwing with me cuz that's
what they do a lot you know oh yeah so
so I got boom I got started to get
uptight now when you get uptight you
blow it even more so finally I got so
nervous cuz now Brian wasn't even
looking at me he would deliver his line
being somebody else so I went up to the
director and because I'm so nervous
now enthroned I went up to the director
I said hey look am i holding up stuff am
I you know screwing up I mean my he said
know why I said while I've been gone up
on lines and I think Brian is mad at me
he said hell with him hahaha which which
kind of was cool he said I'm not doing
anything get back there you know I get
back into the sea Yes Mother and and it
was fine after that but still there was
this thing between which I may have made
up between me and Brian which was kind
of you know a little edgy there and so
that's after a breaking bad bet that's
when I phoned everybody and set them out
I don't need this I i'm gone i'm doing
my own work if I spy I don't mind first
of all I one thing people and may not
know this for me the smaller the part
they may not know the hardest to
memorize because you see something
sherry out of context you come in and as
the weirdo delivery you have dungarees
you're not info hey amber what you do
today I got coffee that you could
memorize it took two and four when
you're the weird guy coming in and
especially if you have scientific lab
things or its and I used to try for
that's why I did homeless stuff they
don't go to lash yeah I don't have
doctors you just come in and you know
but do you have it that the smaller
department was my pen + all right I'm
done the small part is more pressure to
memorize because it's one line I
remember when I was a writer on Seinfeld
for a season one guy kept flubbing a
line and Larry David's gonna lose focus
goes would loin that's my Larry David
pressure the King good is [ __ ] one
line and I'm thinking yes it's harder to
do one line because you're the guest
weird guy you have to hit it out of the
park and it's somewhat like you said
pressure and well I thought you already
had with the business tell your friends
story you mr. heckles the next door
neighbor and how you thought alright
I've got a regular gig I'm gonna be a
regular friend yeah that's all that that
had I thought you said you're done after
that no no but I've been done a lot yeah
I mean yeah I in anything when you when
you give up what's your what's paying
the rent when you give up what's paying
it you know you need to be hit a couple
of times hard before you you just don't
walk away just for no reason or just one
time but when I was doing a mr. heckles
I done for shows you know just one at a
time you know hey we want you back hey
we walked back a 12 pack and then the
when you do six shows you're not hired
you have to be recurring they pay to
hold you yeah you you can't be paid less
than a very big salary and says you're
you are now recurring character well I
done for so i was like thinking hey
maybe maybe maybe and right in the
inception of the show right when you
have the most hope you're in the
beginning they're forming characters
yeah so I did four and then my agent
called cuz they were a long time between
these four you know it wasn't like hey
we're gonna have your back you just get
a quantity we want you get so I did the
fourth and then a long time goes by my
agent calls up and he says hey you got
you got a I got some good news and bad
news for I go okay well what's the good
news he says you got a fifth friends he
and me both knowing what that meant yeah
i'm on the cusp yes wow man that's so
cool wine at the time friends was like a
mega it was mega hit because they said
now was in the third or fourth year
ready and you said that he had an
interesting it started with the craft
service you know bagels and then by the
time he's salmon and shrimp and maybe
you can tell how good a show is doing by
the craft services table yeah so at this
point the fifth the fifth what the
fourth one it was a groaning board so
okay so i say that so well okay so it's
a fit the fifth one you know i'm back
wow that's cool what could be the bad
news he says they're killing you uh-oh
what he says yeah there they killing you
off I go why why I don't know why so I I
was so incensed I mean really intense
because in my
I had already bought a house I was
standing in the driveway I would
actually stand in the driveway and your
fantasy yeah yeah yeah literally and I
mean it was a house where was the house
can it was held oh yes so I mean in
between your back you got the fifth show
and the bad news that was I bought the
house yeah yeah there's some people
literally buy it but they're smart you
so when I showed up at the acted at the
table together the tabl read you know
there's salmon and hawks and stay hidden
the science could I started to interrupt
but I but I've had things where you're
the guest guide to giving gifts at
scrubs we're picked up and they're
giving them plasma TVs and hugging and
I'm just the guest guy ya Ullah so all
that is going on in these millions of
people for the phase I think maybe the
first show of the season you know so
yeah where's a brag when number one and
so I just March over i see the to the
three producers just better deal Thea
yeah they're standing talking to
themselves in the midst of this goes
like a cocktail party that's what it was
only only everybody had juice instead of
you know right so but it was that big
and so I walked over and they turned to
me and said Larry and I go what the hell
you people doing man and they were just
shocked they just I what and they didn't
know what to say yeah why'd you kill me
yeah yeah nice and what the hell are you
what did you do what the hell did you do
me if you said the f you could say it
here well no I just said well and they
were just Stockton it would shocked and
stunned and I thought oh my god what
have I just done I you know I just like
uh and so they said well we uh want a
week but you said they they built a mr.
heckles apartment you were all excited
that was on the fourth sugar on you have
your own set this is yours that was the
fourth show so I figured you know hey
I've got an apartment so right after
that nobody they didn't say anything
they just said well um it was a writing
thing didn't know what to say so I kind
of faded back
I then it had sunk in what I had just
done and because conversations stop they
yelled it I yelled it out loud and so
conversation stopped and so I backed
away I just said oh okay listen cool and
I just went to the craft service table
but from that point on till I was
released at the end of the shoot nobody
talked to me no but if I was at the
craft if I if there's people at the
craft service table and I went over they
walked away I mean immigration shine
weird yeah it was just weird but looking
back on it I i I'm sorry that I the only
yeah regret I have is me thinking that I
did a bad thing me telling them that was
a great thing no no it's just you know
to be able to say what the hell you know
there's two ways to look at it like I i
I'm on eggshells every show cuz you want
to be brought back you've ever to show I
easy even if it's a show I miserable you
wanna hear i'll have shows these kids
shows where they throw food at me and
the skinny middle-aged guy and they
kicked me in the head i gotta want to do
this but you still won't here at the end
we'll have you back you still want that
so so there's a part of me that goes
yeah you got it like stay at it away
there's another part that hear stories
about guys like a [ __ ] you you'll give
me this and their respected and they get
stuff so i get confused yet I mean
people that go get me this and I'm not
taking your [ __ ] you know they mean well
I just thought at when it was all over
and I went home I said okay and that
started me on the I don't belong here
it's just that I that it's just I can do
something else yeah that that I'm doing
the wrong thing I'm making good money at
doing the wrong thing but I'm doing the
wrong thing and I've always thought
since since then that until I finally
spawn my agent said okay it's over thank
you we have the same agent I had a
similar thing that um oh I had I left
him sorry I I was that it was a cubicle
thing you know you see these people
working yeah yours and offices that's my
idea of show be well get working in
Hollywood
that's why I left was it was cubicle
work well but for me I was on the road
as a stand-up and I never trusted my
feelings I go why am I miserable am i
sore loser might not trying hard enough
people steal too much you should love it
and my act is very low key and subtle
and they switched me with the middle Act
or I'm in Texas and they're screaming
out anti-jewish things and it never felt
right and I never and took many years to
accept my heart fell out of it I like
telling stories but not these comedy
clubs with a drunk and you're following
a guide it does a mariachi thing and
spits at the audience you know and
screams out theme songs it's in the
right venue I'd like to do it but not
the the thing so I was so thrilled when
I start doing guest spots to say oh I'm
not on the road as a comedian I'm in
show business I thought he executives
are seeing me but then it yes it did
feel like a day job but now that I'm
expressing myself my book maybe we'll
have you back and my Seinfeld your
kindle single and friend Vinnie these
are things I didn't I made money from
the kindle single but their labors of
love expressing myself and even this
podcast i don't think i'll make money
from but I'm enjoying this so when you
have those things now the guest star
stuff is kind of fun if it comes to me
effortlessly because it's not the one
thing I do it's just hey I do this too
and I used to pooh-pooh it like years
ago going oh I've never been a regular
and like I said I'm hearing Brad Garrett
complaining he's only making 400,000 in
episode and raise making two million and
and you know when and and they're all
getting the script to the next one
they're getting their gifts they're
hugging each other talking about their
houses but now that I'm older I go you
know I appreciate its having lots of
different adventures and and one of the
things I appreciate the most is um I've
done a few guest spots on kids shows
have you done those like the Drake and
Josh or wizards of waverly place died I
think I maybe did one long long time ago
but know that you know and as broad and
stupid as they are they like vaudeville
like the only fun one the ones that
aren't fun is when they want me to be
Ben Stein on
quaaludes like the joke is talk slower
Fred I'm a very excitable teacher it's
not fun talking slowly deliberately but
when kids would kids come up to a now 21
or adults go you aren't a Drake and Josh
to be part of someone's childhood is
something is very special when they
recognize a kid so so I still I am yes
it's you got to be creative I learned
and and you know when I was younger you
did one thing you know I hang out with
this guy Jimmy who you were at flap is
with a 27 year old Chinese guy comedian
and I thought to me envies him he's got
the whole world ahead of him but then
apart but when I had the whole world
ahead of me I had so much more
depression and anxiety cuz was ahead of
me and the pressure got to get a pilot
got to make it happen now then that'd a
moldering the expectations are less just
do a quirky thing here and there you
know I'm saying well I know what you're
saying but that's not how are you
looking up the medicine look at it that
I'm talking to the mic now this is so I
have the whole world ahead of me that's
me too well I think I think it would be
difficult because here you are doing
what you you know having it it's a doing
what I've always wanted to do and I
somebody said hey you could be an actor
and get a lot of money and I thought
well did you write a cool one did yeah
and did you have the same thing Larry I
had like i said before you run these
sets thinking holy exactly to see me i'm
in showpiece i'm making a living showbiz
i'll be on more TV shows but for me I
just stayed at that level so so did you
think you're just moving along I I
didn't know why it wasn't as happy as I
now okay yeah i was just kind of numb to
in my situation in other words i thought
i'm an actor i'm making money and a lot
more money and this can go on for a
while because i'm i'm doing ok I I yeah
I had the same thing so I had never
bothered me until it started internally
I said well I don't belong here and that
that's and then each time I had some
sort of these lines are too
hard to memorize I gotta stay up all
night to memory so what am i doing this
you know so you basically had a reach a
point of so much pain and discomfort to
like me yeah and it just wasn't this is
not a I were a and when i called my and
this is it really interesting a lot of
my friends and even my grandfather they
reach a point where you go through a
marriage raise kids and then the kids
leave the house and then you have an
empty empty nest thing okay I've never
gone through that but I have friends who
went through that go through that and um
my grandfather did the same thing he
when the kids got out of the house you
know that ended and I would go visit him
and they stop both grandfather started
do crazy things from the empty nest
syndrome they started to spend money
like crazy or they started to one of my
grandfather's bought a red convertible
so you're having the empty nest thing
now well meat sale smoking pot all
decided what is that really that you
they they were put away or they were put
to a home or they were the money the
money was taken away from them and they
were considered uh not all what is he
the old old word was all sina sina they
were they were becoming senile that was
the label for them and so they were
looked at like that and then when i gave
up call my agent and I said okay it's
over I'm out what are you gonna do i
don't know i don't care i'm out and i'm
going to sit at home and so something or
you know just hang until something
occurs to me which is scary so I oh yeah
yeah it's and then there's this time
where nothing is going on but I'm not
going back and you just say that and I
thought okay this is the empty nest but
my I've given up everything that I've
worked too till now and then this empty
land then I started going back when was
the last time I had fun that was the
next thought right and then I said well
when I was a stand-up comedian
why because you were doing your own
stuff and nobody was telling you to
memorize this and nobody was ordering
you around good or bad I was doing my
own stuff I was having fun man so I
start to go back to doing that and then
they suddenly realized what my
grandfather was doing no they weren't
senile since their life was finished for
that point empty nest I took i raised
the family I got them out of the house
i'm a good you know father they go back
to what what was going on before they
started that trick well I was a single
guy well in their foot in their
grandfather I don't know if this is the
same thing I'm not plug in my book but
no no I'll never make a penny there was
a lawsuit but the thing is I had the
goal I wanted of a book published about
the guest star life i never thought i'll
make a lot of money it'll be a
best-seller all i want to do was have
the book published it took 10 years so
it's that same passion when you want to
have something done it's not about i'll
make the money or make this and i have
that about expressing myself and what
Larry's talking about and Larry's like
me and I don't fit into puzzles either
we're who we are I'm not going to adapt
to you know the stuff so you get to a
point where you know when you're wasting
your time on these auditions and
everything yo or or you can look it the
other way is that you finally find out
who you are really and I think that's
what happened but once I gave up I
called and said okay I'm out that was
the inkling so this is what I dotting to
find out this is what I wanted to say
like I got to a point where i got ruined
in a good ways because i did an
animation series for about four seasons
and you come in you don't shave like I
am now you're having fun and you know so
i didn't have the desperation and i did
the movie Fred and Vinny and I did the
books and i can't wait a minute it's
this i love so you so then i'd made it
harder to go in these cattle call
auditions for stuff I'm not right
forever New York Jewish accent so then I
got to somewhere one audition was a big
thing for you know the what's his name
zach galifianakis saved not him but the
kind of hey dude and he's taking swigs
he's the philosopher dude rule number
three with chicks and he's the slob
so not me so I had a few times where I
walked out of auditions I go cool and I
but it was liberating and scary as hell
because in one way it's like it's such a
freedom to go I can well I don't even
think I'm brave there's one audition I
walked out of not because there's no way
I could do it there's no way i could say
the words in front of this group of
people after waiting an hour so it was
liberating but a scary go Fred once you
do this there's no going back what's
next so it gets scary but I again I
still love acting if someone wants me in
something if something right that being
said we had the same agent and he's a
character in that I wrote about my book
and he doesn't mind that he'd always
wanted to try to get something for free
like I wrote on Seinfeld and they did
the dvds where I was doing commentary as
a writer and he goes there's no money
but I got real creative they're going to
give you a see every season of seinfeld
DVD and me too so you pick up mine and
bring it to me ago I'm not to get
delivery boy I'm not going to bring you
know this is already i was getting
resentful because every job was someone
i worked with someone asks for me not
something is that ok that level ok
that's not saying they did but they
would say we got you this thing so so
then every time a new season of seinfeld
would come out he'd call me up did you
get your DVD set I didn't get mine yet I
go stop with that you know and he and
then so then I did this movie little man
in the same thing they want me when you
were on the commentary they don't pay
you but he goes I got creative again 12
dvds we'll split him up little man I can
first of all why we splitting them you
supposed to get ten percent and I go you
saw a little man with me at the premiere
it's a kid see cuz ya if free I want him
so so basically he's a real good guy and
what I loved about him was that he did
nothing because i hate auditions to i
know from experience yeah well I would
when they had fax machines and the sides
would come in and 9i go stop stop too
many pages you know I again I know I'm
so specific and almost everything i get
is someone wants me so so i'm going this
guy's great because i hate
ditions and I was getting spoiled doing
creative things but then I start
thinking you know hanging out with the
young guy Jimmy you know maybe maybe I
should try to do pilots and his things
out there one of his stories was one
time I stopped by mike's office and I
said hey how come no auditions he goes
it's dead it's dead he points his
computer like that's evidence so then it
goes to say hi to Gloria go what's going
talk to you I'm praised um preço I
thought it was dead you know so this one
agent never submitted me for anything
and my cuzzo she just the sons of
anarchy and gritty shows but it's more
thing so then I thought all right I want
to leave yeah I cuz one part of the
agency totally shut me out because I I
used to like lie and I didn't want to do
an audition to I got a voiceover job i
wish i could and if i had as many
voiceover editions are jobs as i'd be
tom kenny it'd be a gazillionaire the
makeup to get finally such saying I
depart doesn't feel right if I go in
there and read for the southern redneck
I'm gonna suck and they'll never bring
me in again I'm not a southern redneck
so the winch goes all right and then you
think they get it and then I never hear
from them again so long story short I
finally leave them find a new agent and
I'm relieved because he doesn't submit
me anymore too yes but I wanted to show
I was trying and I want to ask you about
playing Kramer now is interesting now
the people I hope are listening usually
the way it goes if you're someone like
Larry who's been around if you have to
audition you do a thing like go to
producers if you're starting out if
you're not if you're more green it's
thing called day what's a called a first
read where it's just 40 50 people for a
casting agent and then if they like you
they say wait around come back late in
the afternoon or another day for the
producers so usually for a guest spot
you audition for the producers with
about 10 other people and then they book
you now why tell the story when you play
Kramer you had to come in four times for
a guest spot of 55 now why was that and
I I think even at that I go no but you
knew it was
the biggest biggest show like what what
were they making you do different each
time and I have no idea to this day and
when I and that was the other thing you
know the audition show of the audition
process soul-killing I never I never
understood the process because I what
why I went five times was because I
liked the part that was all but what
would I having you do different each
time like when they get that you look
like cream your your lanky or hysterical
you should be crane I mean with her
other people like you there what was it
was so long it was who's always short
people bald people to be Kramer for yeah
I mean no but I was the only guy who
looked like Michael and Michael I'd uh
yeah I was the only guy who looked like
the guy who Kramer really was the real
Kramer I kind of looked like him as did
Michael but other than me and Michael
and we never auditioned at the same time
I never met him at the audition the
people who I auditioned with for Kramer
were people who didn't look anything
like me short fat bald old young I mean
it was really weird so tell me about
what oh yeah good about the mic so again
why I never I never understood the
process but I liked the part and since
it was not on the air there was no
reason for me to think it was going to
be big or small or great did you have to
read the same scene and yeah I made the
same scene each time and each time there
was five different other or six
different other people in a rendition
Ingush inning with me but they were
still not not Michael Richards and they
didn't look anything like me and there
was always one guy in the room there's
always there was Jerry there was a Larry
the management Costanza you know George
George and so I didn't but I didn't know
who larry was I didn't know which guy I
didn't know it was her then yeah
no they're even Larry existed I there
was five or six people in the room three
of which I recognized from other things
I was a big fan of Seinfeld and I knew I
assumed that one of the guys was a
director and one was a producer so who
is this this other guy and I was getting
mad at him because this guy would keep
on asking me to come in the door again
you know the what Michael Richards
finally you know yeah he'd say come in
the door again do a framer entrance for
the Kramer oh yeah no it was it was it
we know that was on the air it was just
this new thing I'm right I got mixed up
it was on the air for a while so I kept
on coming in the door each time you know
trying to be funny and this guy this
bald guy kept on saying do it again do
it again and when you go out but like
here wasn't in the hallway when you go
out of the room to come in yeah you were
in the lobby a you you were in the
waiting room where all the other accents
away and the secretary so they would
wonder you know why is this guy coming
in and going at you know like what did
you do differently so I nothing cuz I
didn't know what was going on I just
wanted the part but the last time the
fifth time I was ready to also bark at
them I saying what the [ __ ] you people
doing no why am I here all the time make
up your mind so they said this guy this
bald-headed guy said come in again for
the third time in this one audition come
in again I said to the secretary when I
got out there I said who is the bald guy
and she said that's Larry David you
writes and produces it and I said oh cuz
I was gonna go in there and [ __ ] shoe
his head off but I won't you know
crystal every day right so I went in
there I was writing nice i did the thing
and I left and I said to my agent I you
know I'm Mike I said don't i don't care
if i don't get i'm not going back there
they're crazy over there and that's when
I got the call to you now a bunch of
questions and one of them let me see
what's from asked before before sign
old well what was the thing he got he
appeared in my favorite WKRP episode was
that the TV acting role he was most
recognized before seinfeld and friends
like people come up to me to go where do
i know you from or they hear me talk
you're famous tell me where and i have
to list my credits a usually you know if
it's a teen I go wizards of waverly
place i always start with seinfeld rain
and they go know what else if it's a
black guy I say rebound little man do
people ask where they know you from what
is it I I did that for like maybe two or
three or four hundred times and then I
just blow him off I can't give you the
story I was in st. Louis and I was in a
shoe store and I was buying a pair of
shoes and these he's like 14 year old
kids come in about half from pepper
black pepper white their little gang
well gang kids came in when I was 16
ma'am you know that he was hurting them
and they come in and they come over and
they go oh man look who that is and they
came over to me they surrounded me and
they were all be me i forgot to say
Billy Madison home alone yeah sorry i'll
shut up telestar fun so they said um
what what what are you in no that's like
a already i had been doing a couple of
years of it so I froze I go well I don't
know if I can you know man no no we
really like you what do you in what do
you in that and I started there's an
greatest this I listed about three of
Mary but they're saying no no no no and
I so finally I said look I can't stand
here and give you my entire credits and
so they this one little kid who was
asking all the questions said to the
others let's get out of here this guy
sucks he's a real creep let's go and
they walked out
how cool of a kid must be nestled he was
concerned and I stopped doing it after
that I said I'll blow them all off yeah
no no I'm sorry sir go find out where
you saw me and come back and I'll talk
to you what do you just stop it you
people think you're ever anyone else cuz
i get i think i'm there they're married
to their cousin or so i I've gotten we
see I'm the type of guy I'm very
isolated unless they're obnoxious people
conscious people will come up to me to
go I don't mean to bother you and then
I'm talking now I'm bothering them like
a mature married couple and now i'm
following them around i'm so glad they
broke up the isolation the only time i
don't like it is when so good who are
you who are you and they're poking in
the chest or i've had a few people
recognize me then ask for money you got
two dollars and but this happens where i
learned not to argue with people someone
else it system someone else I go no I'm
like yes you are like there's a guy
sadly he passed away and he was in I'm
Broadway Danny Rose and he was in the
Warriors and people think I'm himi at a
droopy eye they go you and the Warriors
I got no no i wasn't i know you mean yes
you were I wasn't ago you sure like I
would have forgotten I was in a seminal
wolf the hell movie and I when you're
right i forgot you can't argue with
these people well I mean yeah but you
know you got to take a 11 each
individual at some people are really
nice and they recognize mean they say
hello and i say hello and okay it's cool
it's that some people don't realize
they're obnoxious yeah because you know
i'm in their living room but they're not
in mine you know and they don't know
that and there's no way to say hey you
think you know me but you don't know me
is there any misconceptions like with me
it's um rich like these black guys
recognize me the fact that black has
nothing to do with it um but they point
to the Hollywood Hills they go he must
live up there and I want to take the
hand no and point it where it really is
you know it's look I uh huh all the
things that we've talked about their
part of being an actor and either you
like it or you don't
but you're an actor I'm not an actor so
it behooves me to keep on reminding me
that I'm not an act I'm a stand-up
comedian I'm a writer and I'm a
filmmaker that's what I am and these
people are relating to me like a neck
and now if I was an actor I love that oh
don't bang the table okay i love about
but but i'm not all right let me ask you
have you had any great great experiences
as an actor I mean it's fun like what's
the fun stuff have you ever the fun
stuff is hitting your marks and getting
it right has there ever been a time when
you work with someone go i can't believe
i'm working with so-and-so is to watch
him as a kid or for me it was I know it
sounds crazy i had a man crush on treat
Williams I loved him in the movie hair
do you know treat Williams is I'm so
starstruck I love done Raymond meeting
Charles Durning and peter boyle because
i love Dog Day Afternoon and asked and
taxi driver and and I was going to ask
you did you ever work with anyone you
had a crush on cuz right so you work
with holly hunter and we were talking
about i had a crush on her nobody was
all mine no i don't know whether it's
you know my ADHD or what are the other
thing was that you tourettes know what
is it that's well it's that no I don't
have a crush on anybody I I relate and
that's that's one of the mistakes FMS
was not an actor and that's why i can
say that is no I i worked with a holly
hunter and she was just a person no I
know she's a personable doing no but
that's a healthy way to approach it no
it's not oh not but you so you're saying
that you've never been starstruck I know
that no I maybe I'm star stuck when I'm
watching the movie yeah but that's the
movie and I go wow man I wish I could
you know I well yeah they say when I
meet my meet them know they're they're
human being well you know actually and I
don't relate to them that way and
sometimes it's not cool Oh relate to
them that way well I've had egg bryan
cranston i would just you know go up and
ask him questions and some time
he was nice and he was a human being and
sometimes she was Walter White yeah but
when he was you know when but I don't
know I've never had I just got to say if
I was an actor I would of course I you
know filmmakers I'm starstruck when they
yeah actually Quentin Tarantino was the
one guy I wanted to meet the most and I
love him more not for his movies his
passion the way he talks about movies
he's and this is farmers market table
you came to once and an Amber came this
morning and he was there to see Paul
Mazursky and I had this delusion he'd go
for fred stoller I saw you these two big
parts you should be a hitman not just a
delivery guy he had no clue who I was
but he loved Ronnie shell this character
acting all these disney movies but when
you so when that cliche don't meet your
idols I used to love Donald Sutherland
because people thought i was like Donald
Sutherland and I'd see him in these
movies and he's this goofy guy with all
these macho people and Dirty Dozen so I
did extra work on a movie became heaven
help us and there was a there was like a
400 extras and the ad goes any comedians
and one guy went up and I said I'm a
comedian I thought I could get the
direct his attention and I was killing
only because they would stop for
attention and you know and I was doing
real jokes or my act and Donald
Sutherland pushed me off because he was
trying to be funny because get off
anyone could get laughs doing jokes
about a Jewish holiday and he and he was
really and then I would pass in the
halls say hi and and he would look me in
the eye and and everyone was like for
the next few days I was the extra I was
like the star all the extras you're
funny you're funny i didn't get apart
but i was disillusioning meeting Donald
Sutherland well that's why I don't want
to like PSI i don't i don't think
starstruck is cool that starts drive but
again it's that teen thing nor McDonald
said something he's most impressed by
people he met before he got into the
business now when you're in the business
I mean I'm more excited meeting someone
from a show i watch it as a kid like the
Bob Newhart show like Jack Riley then if
I met George Clooney it's that it's that
that you know childhood stuff okay
his lies that you're to me what's
exciting is people who made me want to
be a character actor and I meet them so
did you not want to be a character actor
girl I never want to be a connector I
never want I was I was tricked into it
by buying a lot of money and here you
can do this but uh I'm a stand-up
comedian is funny that's it I I like
being creative and expressing myself
like this is fun if people like it is
this going okay yeah okay but I I was
tricked him to stand up because I I
didn't know how you became a character
actor and then someone said Freddie
Prinze Jimmy Walker they went to the
improv they did their act and they got
on The Tonight Show then I got a sitcom
ago that's all i have to do so I
fantasize being on The Tonight Show
going this is only my second time doing
stand-up and I remember when I was a
stand-up Robin Williams would film all
day Moscow on the Hudson and then he'd
come in all night two sets and at the
catch a rising star and I go if I'm in a
movie I'd be so nervous I want to wake
up early but he did you know so it's all
different temperaments so could I you
have any questions could I ask what so
much yeah [ __ ] well shouldn't you be our
talking to me now but uh shouldn't one
be drawn to that which has ease
absolutely you know this is a thing I
I'm all into the deepak chopra stuff you
got a weird lately but effortlessness
and yes I used to beat myself up
thinking you know Fred you should write
anime movies it's in or you should do
look like a guy in a middle evil movie
but that's not me no there's nothing
wrong with it coming effortlessly you
got to put work into it but it shouldn't
be this crazy strain so I'm all for
effortlessness I just think sometimes
we're confused on exactly what we want
and then you know if you're starting to
get a bunch of guest roles you're like
wash I should look I should love this so
was there a time I'm curious like when
you weren't doing so much stand-up and
you started to get booked more and TV
shows was there a time where you're like
okay well I guess I am an actor
never wanted to be one I know but what
happened was I was I went from stand-up
comedy to second city and then second
city to the committee which is an
offshoot of the second city and then
from that I became an actor but I became
an actor because as I was in the show
the the committee show up in San
Francisco I was there for 10 years in
between shows you know like on a day
offer i took off a week i would go down
a Hollywood to do something but that was
a lark that was hey not only my in this
show and I'm it's a successful show in
San Francisco but every once in a while
I get that home when I wrote on design
that off and then when the committee
stopped that's all i had was being in
hollywood and doing acting and then it
was a drag although i didn't kind of
realize it until the back thing yeah so
I was tricked into it in a way acting is
great it hold out my regular and I was
stuck with the thing i didn't is great
if it's not the only thing you do if
it's not the only thing you do but I was
like Larry in a comfort zone when they
used to be a lot of sitcoms doing a lot
and I'm so busy doing them and reading
and running around that you know now
when you say San Francisco a question
people have is that how you got escaped
from Alcatraz yeah I was up in San
Francisco and that was like a lark you
know and you had a big part a huge part
I never did a drama and I was I was it
fun or you probably so yeah it was fun
because I was still working in San
Francisco so I had a day a weird day gig
night kick other words my day gig was
working in improv in san francisco in a
hit show lines around the block that was
my day gig i was at night but in other
words you know don't quit your day cake
so all of a sudden i was invited down to
LA to read for a Clint Eastwood movie
hey man how cool something to talk about
when I come back you know so and then I
looked into that because it we should
meet up that would be so much fun being
in a prison and not being the nebbish
and not being a delivery guy and I was
than a [ __ ] though that was where it's
not still you're in prison I i have
always beatin em ish but I want to be I
am I'll always be like I did a TV movie
with Tony Danza in Canada it was so much
fun we were garbage men and riding on a
truck to be even even that being a
locker room rather than the the stale
sets i mean people look at me would
stand up like it's the ultimate it's a
great thing if you're great but you
can't dabble so i know people when i
fell into his fell into a writing job on
seinfeld and people resented me you fell
into this is the ultimate dream but who
we to judge what people's dreams are
it's where the passion goes and
everything let me let me ask you some
more questions awful this is not a good
question from sylvia graves what would
be his perfect dream role so we use
dimas the outlaw I'm ademas that's one
of your character that's what I'm
writing that's the movie a good that's a
good answer um thank you um let me see
Lou DiMaggio s asked him how he found
himself hanging out with Bob Dylan and
the band back in the basement tape days
whoo wow that was who knows I mean I can
tell you how I mean that came out of
that that's like yeah lightnings
catching lightning um I got a call from
hanging out with got a call from robbie
robertson how I got a call from how I
even got my number I don't know but it
was at the time of big pink you know
their their first album big pink I got a
call from Robbie barberton hey you know
abrupt well yeah and he said I want you
to write a movie for me well for me with
me and I go what did he know you from
the committee and everything that's what
I said well where did this come from how
did you get my number I mean it was
literally I said that I said how did you
get get my number he said I got it from
my agent who called your agent but Bob
Dylan told me to call you I go what how
he said I don't know Bob Bob told me to
call you here with ideal took to call me
so when I went to big when i went to
bearsville to write with robbie and the
and Dylan showed up at one one of the
sessions we were outside and playing
football and he came up to me and I said
what how did why did you tell uh Robbie
to call me where did that come for I
don't know you I mean I know you but I
don't you know what had he said well you
are a state you are a stand-up you were
stand-up comedian in the village right I
go yeah he said well that was when i was
there which was right i remember hearing
his name he said i used to go see you
all the time oh my god so I thought you
were pretty funny and he wanted a funny
movie and I said call Larry so that did
you write the movie no oh well I wrote I
wrote I wrote a 13-page poem because
that's all they were doing and others I
just fall in with what's going on oh
yeah they were all writing songs so I
thought I'd write the the thing as a as
a rhyme and when I showed it to warner
brothers who was paying me this huge
amount to write the movie they said well
where's the script I said well it's kind
of a song and they go what send it here
right away I as I can even sing it for
you he said no no no just send it so I
sent it and they called me back no I
went to see him he said I read it come
to the office so I went when I got back
to LA I went to the office and he said
you owe us 35 thousand dollars haha they
go why said we doesn't pay you for a
song we paid you for a screenplay I said
well that's it you know god that's what
I got that's it the country you want
starstruck then I am never dead
starstruck is a really bad thing I don't
like being starstruck it's not good at
all no I'm unhealthy let me ask you
here's this question like because this
is more up your alley a mumble slam said
I love Larry what's going on with Larry
Hankins Street stories and is there a
chance he'll appear on medical Sal I
could answer the second question if he
is going to be on better called Sally
assume he's not allowed to say but the
first part this guy knows your work
uh what was then there was the mumble
slam he's no no and what we want to know
a larry Hankins street stories Oh Street
stories yeah that's a that's a film
that's Emma dimas that's the second or
third film I've written 3 i'm in the
process of raising the money for the
first one right now well let me ask you
a little thing about me your advice
everyone here now this is maybe my first
one now people give me different advice
Mike who's not here is thinking oh don't
it make it about you you be the focus
donuts that all guests but amber saying
it shouldn't just be me it should be
conversation do you you think fred
stoller and friends so do you have any
advice for what for what this should be
ok Oh for the fog podcast you can chime
in what what do you think I know you've
been trying in your advice I i I'll I
don't know what what is going to the
best way is just to show up every day or
week or whatever and just keep doing
these and you'll find out ok it'll shake
down I cuz Mike was saying you know Fred
you should tell your stories but I've
got been getting my stories in right and
there's uh yeah and I almost think you
have to have a guest all right Mike
disagrees he says it's hard but I will
get one even if it's not a big guy like
Larry it could be my friend child so
quit comedy to become Orthodox Jewish
day again and resents it in me but yeah
yeah you'll get your stories and yes I
got some stories in yeah you know it was
grainy had Oh discardable guess I owe
you so much Larry he's done like I said
a bunch of these favors we had at the
meltdown we had one at sag or we told
these guests our stories um I totally am
on your side with wanting to life is
short and and to me my my mantra is
hospitality expression experience and
expression and and creativity you know
so just to help people relative by
having experience and be creative and
try and think of any other questions
okay
the only other question is what was
Holly Hunter like I'm just kidding I
know uh what was um I was fighting for
LA see that's that's I think that gives
me a guard against being awestruck or
starstruck as I am so into remembering
my lines I don't have time to be
starstruck no I'm not ruling I gotta
remember my lines I had a brush I had a
crush on vicki Lewis a redhead only
because she reminded me as someone else
then I was going to ask her out some too
dude she's live with Nick Nolte in
Malibu for ten years she's not going to
go from Nick Nolte to your little
apartment without the air conditioning
okay and and they were right and then I
you know Hollywood is so weird because
you have this rear andaman acting class
and there was a model but she seemed to
get me I thought I go maybe I'll ask her
out turned out she was dating Kiefer
Sutherland and before that Nicolas Cage
it's always Nicolas Cage Kiefer
Sutherland then fred stoller you know
but it's always this did another woman I
was with before me she dated Harry Dean
Stanton and Ed Begley Jr I love the
randomness of oh you're right you're up
there you with the Stars yeah it's
something to brag about that I was with
someone that was with Ed Begley Jr you
know you got it you got to get excited
well I'm for the first one this is ok
pacing not too long not too short and
and and and under the hope that someone
may be listening to this Larry what
would you like the plug or push um
kickstart is what i don't know i'm gonna
i'm going to probably do just go to my
face but i'll make an announcement at
some point on facebook i'm going to be
doing a evening of my show business
stories in in santa monica something
some well I'm going at at and we had it
we had a taste of that aren't they great
yeah um it was really great it was
really nice meeting you I am I'm not
starstruck though okay um what would you
like to say amber and uh what plug stuff
yeah oh you can follow me on twitter
amber toes are not told him not tours
and I
toz ER and sometimes i'ma stand alone
hey kid twitter twitter i got to get on
Twitter that's fine yeah it's my
favorite platform and um I'm we're gonna
have a theme saw and I'm gonna come here
and every week guest or not even if it's
bringing my landlord and showing him
evidence they don't have a lot of money
I'm going to keep coming here and please
this is all things comedy supported how
do we support you by the merch you do
the things I love bill bar and al and
wow so bill burr is cool I mean it's
funny he's a funny guy yeah there's a
funny haha now Fred that is funny way
there was a mission to build yeah he's
appointed me now wait a minute that
would have been funny bill burr Elber
was a great guy he I don't get okay to
get Star Search but I get starstruck I
get intimidated thinking he's gonna go
hey you're a [ __ ] I'm a muscular guy
hey uh uh yeah he works with who he is
but he's a great guy he was so so yeah
alright this is what i get i get i like
when someone's aware of me that i like
and he was yeah so that's what i like
when they go i'm a fan of yours right so
that was good and here let's see what
happens let's see if the pilot this
pilot goes this is our pilot cool man
thank you so much